au moment où les premiers vacanciers de
février gagne les stations de sports
d'hiver je vous propose de découvrir
cette nouvelle pratique de glisse le
kite ce qu'est leur mariage du
cerf-volant et des skis pour des
amateurs qui n'ont pas froid aux yeux
reportage au col du lautaret agnès
garder frédéric basket
on m'avait fait cadeau d'un tout petit
cerf-volant pilotable pour enfants comme
pour adultes et puis j'ai commencé à
apprendre et tout de suite on a fait
tilt avec la montagne en ses dires il ya
moyen de se promener dans les montagnes
avec ça les derniers nés des freeriders
mot anglais qui désigne les fous de la
glisse ils sont une trentaine en france
à jouer au cerf-volant avec des skis aux
pieds
mais attention ce jeu ne s'improvise pas
il faut forcément avant de défier la
pesanteur passer quelques heures cloués
au sol allez latent qui le tour complet
manipulation qui est très importante à
maîtriser s'est décrochée lèvres la
voile c'est à dire pouvoir là fallait
complètement et stopper quand dans
l'attraction partir de ce moment là
quand on a compris c'est une
manipulation là on peut conserver s'est
tranquillement quoi vous défile une
voile de 5 et 6 ou 7 mètres carrés selon
le niveau de pilotage et la force du
vent se vent qu'il faut savoir prendre
comme il vient à la montée et à la
descente devant il est l'idée qu'un
pression montagne dont il ya des failles
et des grosses montées en puissance puis
comment on remonte un peu les pentes des
trois arrivées au sommet devant les
trois fois plus fort que quand tu es
parti en bas il faut bien maîtriser les
techniques de base de sécurité à savoir
neutraliser la voile à 100% quand c'est
toi qui peux arrêter s'arrête pas et ça
j'ai eu beaucoup de débutants cent
vallées monte monte monte est arrivé en
haut ils savaient plus quoi faire
on peut tout se permettre distille à
condition de rester prudent car
l'ivresse peut être totale et les cimes
soudainement accessible la en 20 minutes
pascal cédric et les autres se sont
retrouvés à 3000 m d'altitude presque
sans effort pour eux c'est sûr fini les
peaux de phoques et les remontées
mécaniques
ils leur préfèrent la glycéro tractée et
cette pure sensation de liberté